It says, if you encounter the sarcasm tag, take a deep breath and move along.
Is what it says.
Dude, I was like, how is the HTML5 spec actually an engaging read?
Whew.
Wow.
This has been a whirlwind, man.
This year cannot slow down, can it?
No, it can't, dude.
Here we are.
We are in Miami recording the second episode.
I think this one's going to air first, though.
Yeah.
We recorded an episode the day before yesterday with Yusuf Samouda.
And man, is that a good episode.
You guys are in for a good one next week.
Oh, man, it was funny because I was joking with some people that were like, oh, were you on Yusuf's podcast yesterday?
I was like, yeah, I was.
I was the guest, actually.
Dude, seriously, it was so good.
And just a lot of really high technical bugs, a lot of great discussions surrounding client-side constraints in the browser and that sort of thing.
So really looking forward to airing that episode.
And I got to re-listen to it myself.
Yeah, dude.
I mean, it's so awesome, like, seeing somebody who has, I mean, it feels like a niche, right?
But it's just like web hacking, right?
Like, he has managed to, like, corner this niche of, like, ATOs and post message and, like, deep JavaScript bugs.
And you do that, too, man.
Like, don't get me wrong.
Like, but...
Yeah, so I guess one of the things that I kind of want to talk about is takeaways from this live hacking event.
The target is public.
It is Capital One.
Yep.
And it's been a really fun event.
A lot of client-side bugs have rolled out, especially for me.
So there's a couple of good takeaways there.
And one of those is that I wasn't paying enough attention to client-side routing, I don't think, before this specific event.
And like I've been predicting over the past couple months, or even maybe a year at this point since we started the podcast,
client-side path traversal is just going to continue to grow and grow and grow as a bug class.
And we've seen that at this event.
We've seen it at past events.
And it's paying attention to client-side routing is going to be the new C-Surf in the near future.
Yeah, absolutely.
Because there are so many levels of complexity now with just, like, browsers.
How the browser is handling requests that you are going to have to rely on client-side path traversal at a certain point.
Like, C-Surf, within the next 10 years, could not even exist anymore.
Yeah, it's going to be real tricky.
When the browsers remove the same site lacks default sort of caveat that they have, the top-level navigation with a post request within two minutes of the cookie being set,
when that goes away, it's going to be very hard to implement C-Surf's.
By default, it's going to be safe, which is great for the community, but a little bit sad for us.
And so definitely those client-side path traversals are going to continue to be a thing.
And I've seen this event and in past events as well, a lot of really interesting stuff surrounding chaining those client-side path traversals with open redirects.
And then actually being able to control content that's being placed into the application that the application expects to be secure.
Right.
You know, they're trusting their API requests, you know, requests, and you're going to get stuff back.
And sometimes it's HTML and a JSON blob, and then they literally just dump it right into the DOM.
Yeah.
And you've just got XSS.
So, especially when it can be chained with an open redirect, a lot of impact there.
Yeah, absolutely.
So where did you spend most of your time on the event?
Man, I jumped all over the place.
There was a couple things in scope that went out of scope by a certain time.
So I went and focused on the things that were time-sensitive first.
And then for the rest of the event, man, I was just kind of chugging away on client-side stuff.
I've got 40, bless my heart, I've got 40 bugs right now.
40.
And I was up until 3 a.m. last night finding another high and getting it submitted and getting it fully exploited.
That's awesome.
So I am toasty right now.
But I'm expecting some good results.
I'm a little bit nervous right now, though, man, because it's like the event has officially closed.
Yeah.
And they've only paid $150K, I think, the last time we looked at it.
And they might be paying them out right now as we're recording.
Yeah.
Yeah, $150K.
So I think that they're lagging a little bit behind on this.
So I'm interested to see how it turns out tonight.
Yeah, I have a feeling it'll probably end at least $300K or $400K total bounties.
That's what I think, at least.
Yeah.
I think a lot of it is there was so many dupes, especially on those time-sensitive areas.
Like you said, I remember I checked on the first day, and there was like 5 or 10 people who had 25 reports in.
And I was like, oh, okay, I need a new time zone.
Like, wow, this is crazy.
It's crazy.
And for those of you that aren't familiar with the live hacking event sort of set up, how it works in these competition is there's a dupe period for the first week of hacking.
So you've got all these top hackers hacking on one target, and then the bounties are inflated.
And then, but obviously there's going to be a lot of dupes because a lot of the top hackers are going to find similar bugs.
So within that first week, all of the bounties that are dupes are all split evenly between all the reporters.
So it's very important within that first week to find all of the things that you can find that you think are not specifically, you know, Rhinorader bugs or TechnoGeek bugs, right?
Right.
And get those submitted, get those in before the dupe period ends, and then you can kind of focus on the bigger brain stuff, right?
Yeah.
And I did a similar approach.
So there was a flag that they had set out in the mobile apps.
And I was like, well, that's, that's my, that's my jam.
So let me go.
He said, all right, here we go.
Yeah.
So I went in on that.
I got that super quick.
I think, I think I got it.
It hasn't been paid out yet.
You got it first.
I'm pretty sure I got it.
Yeah.
And then I kind of made a, well, it was a mistake, but I didn't know it at the time where I spent most of my time on the mobile apps.
And again, because my niche, right?
So, you know, I was talking with Rezo.
He was like, you know what, dude, just do it.
Like focusing, going, it'll be worth it.
I was like, okay, I'll do it.
And so I started tracking my time this time.
This was the first event I tracked my time.
No way.
Really?
Oh man, you were going seriously.
I was going serious.
Honestly, it really helped with like, I don't know, maybe it's just my ADHD, but like having a timer where like, if I feel like I've been doing something for a bit and just being able to like look up and see, oh, like I'm two hours in or three hours in or whatever.
Like it's good to feel like I'm making progress and not just like I'm sitting still.
There's something about putting hours in that that's gratifying in and of itself.
Right, right.
But unfortunately, I didn't find anything else other than that.
I felt like one low and it got close and forward.
The mobile app was tight, man.
It was very tight.
And even across the other mobile hackers, I think there were only like one or two other accepted reports on the mobile app scope.
So that was definitely sad to see.
Yeah, yeah.
They had a ton of obfuscation on it.
I spent a bunch of time getting around that.
Oh yeah, was that what it was?
Oh, for sure, like once I get past this obfuscation, good.
Like I'm going to find all the bugs as soon as I get past this.
I got past it at like hour six.
Oh my gosh.
It was just like testing endpoints, looking for other entry points, like looking for anything and just nothing panned out.
I even pulled out the full list of endpoints.
I sent them over to Rezo.
He was like, all right, let me fuzz these.
Nothing.
Wow, dude.
Yeah, that's just how the cards lie.
And I know we were going to do a, what did you put in the chat?
A hacker therapy session, man.
So like, how did that make you feel, Joel, in that moment?
I'm not going to lie.
I was like, in the heat of the moment, I was like, you know what?
Maybe I'm done with bug bounty.
Dude, I know, man.
I always feel that way.
And then it's like, you know, it pulls you back in when you find something.
And we've got a bug.
We've got an ATO on a specific site that we need to go finish up.
So maybe after this event, we'll go do that.
And that'll kind of swing us back around into the proper mindset.
Gotta get that momentum going.
Mindset, you know?
Oh, man.
Mindset, grindset.
Yeah, dudes.
But I will say, the nice thing about tracking the time, I felt like because I knew how many
hours I put in, I felt less bad when I decided it was time to cut my losses.
And so when I was like, okay, I'm at 25 hours on this mobile app, I'm done on the mobile app.
I'm not spending more time on this.
If I'm going to hack more on this target, I'm going to look at other scope assets because
this is no longer worth my time.
If I'm going to find anything, it's not going to be on these apps.
I've got a cool story about learning how to cut your losses.
This event, I found what should have been a bug but was not a bug.
There was a specific spot in one of the applications where it was taking a parameter via the hash
and it was taking that parameter.
It was actually doing a domain validation on a different parameter and then using this
parameter as the API host for their fetch stuff that they would do.
I had a very similar bug like this in the past.
Oh, did you really?
Yeah.
And, but here's the thing with that.
So typically this would be an easy, easy dub, but there was a, there's a CSP in place, a
connect source CSP.
Okay.
So that means I can't connect to any website that is not what they had to find.
They've got one website in scope.
They've got self and then they had star.googleapis.com.
Okay.
That's pretty broad.
That is.
So I was looking into that.
I was like, okay, what can I do with that?
And lo and behold, the storage, uh, API for, or the way you access Google storage buckets,
um, the S3 buckets of Google cloud is on storage.googleapis.com.
I was like, great.
I'll just upload a JSON file to a bucket.
And then, um, you know, if I need to do multiple requests, I can like get the timing, right?
Uh, you know, and I can change out the file and that sort of thing.
So far nothing has gone wrong.
No, no, no, no.
You just, like, this is great.
But here's, that's the problem, right?
Because I go all the way down this, this, this, you know, path and then it doesn't work at the end.
So I'll tell you, I'll tell you.
So I plug it in there, give it the host.
It sends out the request.
Boop, boop.
Um, access control, uh, headers for need to be in place.
So you need access control allow origin header.
I'm like, okay, shit.
On the bucket?
On the bucket.
So I was like, okay, uh, you know, Google storage bucket access control header, right?
Oh no.
Okay.
Well first actually I had a different idea.
First I was like, okay, maybe I, I can just use a data URL.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Right.
Actually.
Yeah.
Why not?
Right.
And I was like, okay, great.
And I opened up my browser and I said, fetch data URL and it worked.
And I was like, oh wow.
I can, I didn't know that I could use a data URL with fetch and I can specify the content type
and everything.
I was like, this is really cool.
Um, where do you specify content though?
In the data URL itself.
It's like data, you know, colon.
And then it says like text.
Oh, like text.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Or application JSON or whatever.
And then basics.
It applies when it fetches it too.
Yeah.
And it does.
It's clean.
CSP doesn't like data.
Of course.
I don't know what I was thinking, but I was really, I was really, um, interested to that,
that like, oh wow, I can, I can use a data URL with fetch.
So anyway, then I go to the bucket solution, right?
And so, okay.
I need to solve the access control allow origin header problem.
So I start Googling that and there's a way to set it for the bucket.
I'm like, hell yeah.
So I go ahead and upload the thing and it, and I'm like, all right, you know, I got it
set to star or whatever.
No problem.
Okay.
And I set it up and it's boop, boop.
This request, this fetch request is with mode send credentials.
So there needs to be an access control allow credentials true header in the response.
And you can't set that for Google storage buckets.
But wait, Joel, it gets better, man.
Okay.
Listen to this dude.
Then I'm like, shit, how do I fix this problem?
So I start researching, researching, researching.
Also on storage.googleapis.com is the JSON API for the storage interface.
So you can get like metadata on objects and stuff like that.
Okay.
That one does return, it echoes the origin into the access control allow origin header.
How did that work?
And, and, and it has access control allow credentials true.
Okay.
So it's like, this is perfect.
How do I get my arbitrary, arbitrary data in there, right?
Because it's the metadata URL.
It's not actually, or it's the metadata endpoint.
It's not the actual content.
Well, there's this one weird parameter that says, instead of giving the metadata for this object,
return the actual object content.
And I'm like, yes, this is perfect.
I got it.
And there's a sync too.
There's a window location dot href sync that's right after the call.
So it's, it literally, if it has a JSON attribute, then it just puts it right into window location dot href.
I'm like, hell yeah, this is XSS.
Let's go.
I mean, at this point so far, I'm, I'm, are you pranking me?
It's ups and downs.
No, no, no.
It's ups and downs, man.
And then guess what?
I send it in.
JavaScript URI.
Boop, boop.
CSP script source.
Can't execute anything.
I don't know why I didn't see it.
I went on this whole thing.
There's no script source.
And, and I just.
It's a dead end.
You can't do anything with it.
There's no, there's no JavaScript you can execute.
I, I've tried this and that and the other thing.
Oh, here's the other thing.
It caches the API host in session storage.
Okay.
And then it will use that for another request that, that has sensitive information in the URL.
So I'm like, great, I can link that.
But when it sends the sensitive information via the URL, it clears session storage.
So it's like in session storage, it's supposed to be per tab.
I figured out a way to get that to not work, right?
Okay.
To cache mine and then use it on the page.
It's still, it's still freaking, they, they clear session storage so I can't leak the data.
Dang.
It's useless.
Wow.
Okay.
I was going to ask a couple of things if you tried.
I'm so salty, man.
Before I found out about the CSP, I was going to say, I was going to wonder if you tried redirects for the storage bucket thing to see if you could maybe redirect it to the URL you wanted or at like rapid or something.
But now, now the connect source is going to block anything and there's no way for you to make that initial connection because you can't make CSP, you know, dot or a storage dot.
What about like CSS, like CSS exfiltration?
Yeah, but we have no, no, no, there's no, there's no way to inject.
So then, then there's also sort of a way for you to get HTML injection, but it's in Angular's HTML injection thing.
So it's just totally, it's, it's, it's impossible, man.
I've had six people look at it at the event and all of them are extremely talented client side hackers.
Not a man.
Dang.
So, anyway, man, I, I'll be honest with you.
I sunk probably eight hours into that.
Yeah.
Um, and that was a mistake.
You know, I, I got the full length that I made it in the end, three hours in probably.
And I made that extra hop to, oh, okay, maybe I can leak data via the, you know, poisoning the API host in session storage.
Maybe five or six in, you know?
So maybe that, you know, if that clear session storage thing wasn't there, then maybe I could have actually gotten the exploitation.
But one of the hardest things in bug bounty for me, man, is knowing when to cut your losses.
And I just suck at that.
And, and maybe sometimes that makes us better hackers and maybe that makes us pops bugs.
But I think a lot of time it makes us lose, lose a lot of time.
Right.
And like, it's a trade-off, right?
Because there's always like, if you cut your losses too early, then you definitely could miss something.
You guarantee the miss.
Right.
Like, I mean, assuming something's there, but yes, like the, the miss is significantly more.
But it, like equally, if you keep hacking the miss also, like the other scope and the other things that you haven't looked at, like that miss is still there.
And I, I, dude, I, I've been thinking about this because I like, I don't know if I should adjust anything.
And I don't think I should like, because I don't think I did anything wrong.
Maybe, maybe I should have cut losses and maybe a little earlier.
Yeah.
Maybe I should have spent less time on like the nitty gritty of, of the obfuscation and stuff.
But what I would say, Joel is 25 hours is, I mean, you got a full-time job as well.
Yeah.
So that I, I wasn't really considering that.
I, I, 25 hours is not where I cut my losses in, in normally in these sort of situations.
But I, I didn't really take into consideration the fact that you have, you know, limited time constraints with, with your full-time job.
With full-time job, I was doing about six hours a day.
Yeah.
That's, that's, that's, yeah, that's, that's, you know, yeah.
So, you know, it is what it is.
Um, you know, you can't win them all.
I think I, I've said that to like 10 people.
So, you know, it, it happens.
And, um, I think I'm just going to apply the same, you know, go deep, right?
Like that's what we always say, go deep, keep going, keep going deep, just keep going deep.
And, and notes, right?
Like I was taking a ton of notes and by the end of it, I was looking through my notes.
I was like, I have nothing else to look at here.
Dude, we need to find that.
Every time I, I say going deep in, uh, in, with the Bug County context, I think of that tweet by Tom Nom Nom.
You know, the one I'm talking about?
No, no, no, no.
So dude, he, somebody like tweeted out a, I'll have to see if I can find it, but it's like one of the most legendary tweets I've ever seen.
Someone was like, all right, Bug County tips, you know, go deep, read the manual, uh, you know, push hard, something like that.
And then Tom comment, and a bunch of other ones that are in line.
And then Tom comments, he's like, this is also my approach to sex.
Oh my God.
And I'm like, dude, you're nuts.
This is such, and then it ratioed hard, of course, you know, like it's just amazing.
I think it was hack Luke.
Dude, that's so funny.
Um, wow.
Yeah, man.
Getting intimate with the application, as we say, is, uh, is, is pivotal, um, to these sorts of things.
Uh, so yeah.
And I will say, man, I am, uh, I am, I am intimate with many of the applications right now.
And I, I'm, I'm really looking forward to, uh, not looking at a computer screen for a little while.
I'm going out of the country right after this.
Um, which is, which will be great.
Uh, good time to relax.
And, uh, I'm just hoping these, these bugs pay out the way, the way they should.
Yeah, absolutely.
Dude.
I heard what your total is right now versus what you were expecting.
And I was like, it's going to be a little tricky, man.
It's going to be one of those events.
I'm looking at my phone because I'm like, ah, you know, and, and then the thing is about these, the, the events too, is, you know, it'll, they'll make like a ching sound if you're downstairs, you know, in the hacking room and you'll get the, you know, the pings and stuff like that.
So it's very like dopamine heavy, you know?
Yeah.
Very anticipatory.
So, um, any other, any other cool takeaways from the event for you?
The only other thing that comes to my very tired brain right now is I've, I was very impressed with a specific set of business logic bugs from Douglas Day, uh, Archangel at this event.
He really took his methodology.
He, and he normally collabs.
We called, we, you know, we did an episode with him.
We called him the king of collaboration.
He did a solo, um, a solo event this time.
Yep.
And I was talking to him about some of his bugs and they're just elegant, you know?
And it just, it, it exemplifies perfectly the idea of understanding what, it exemplifies two things.
Understanding the business and hitting them at their pain points and, and really setting a goal for the application.
The other one is setting a goal for the application and just, you know, brooding it into having that goal.
Yeah.
Um, which is something that we talk about a good bit.
So I think he did a really good job with this.
I'm hoping he gets the payouts that he deserves at this specific one.
Yeah.
Um, but you know, we've got time to argue afterwards as well.
So if it doesn't happen event day, it's sad because, you know, you don't make it on the, on the, you know, podium or whatever.
But, um, there's always time to debate afterwards.
Yeah.
I will say, so I also did this event basically solo.
Um, and that was the first solo event I've done in a long time.
Um, I usually lean pretty heavy on collaborations because I really like collaborations and I think they're good opportunities.
But to be quite honest, when you do a lot of collaboration, it's really just like sitting around waiting for somebody else to come up with something and being like, Hey, I have this thing.
And you're like, I can help with that.
I think for you, you know, one of the areas you shine is, is as an exploitationist, you know, like, like there's, there's a lot of things that.
There's a different skillset from, you know, exploiting a bug, exploiting a weird functionality and finding that weird functionality, finding the asset.
That's going to give you weird function.
It's not necessarily recon, right?
You know, recon could be finding the asset and that sort of thing.
Understanding what is weird in application really requires a more intimate knowledge of the application.
And then you take that and you say, Hey, Joel, this is why it's weird.
It's weird.
This is what it would be cool if it could do.
And then, you know, when you have strong exploitationists like yourself and, you know, that you can collaborate with, it works out really well.
Yeah.
Um, but when you, when you spend a long, long time on collaboration, some of those other skills get a little rusty too.
Yep.
Um, which is, which is tricky and, and something you got to go in and be like, okay, I'm self-aware of that.
I got to shake that off and be a little bit more resilient in that regard.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
It's going to take more time.
It's going to, yeah, absolutely.
I dealt with a lot of that during this event and the goal thing.
Um, I think that's one area I probably could have done better.
I didn't set as many goals this event, which I wish I had, I set a couple like soft goals.
Like I, I definitely set more soft goals than I did hard goals.
And I wish I would have gone for more like hard goals, like really go after, like, I want to do this thing.
I want an ATO or I want to bypass whatever, like, and just go, go, go at that.
I think it might've helped a little bit with the focus and sort of the direction of my hacking.
Yeah.
Um, and the one soft goal that I did pursue, it didn't really pan out for, you know, it was just implemented securely.
Um, so.
Sometimes you run into that and you just, you did snag the flag.
Yeah.
Which is good.
Um, so you at least got something to show for it.
Uh, but yeah, that, that goal, that goal oriented mentality is important.
And then you've also got some, I don't know if you want to talk about the thing, but you've also got something else going on right now.
Yeah.
You're taking a lot of time.
Selling a house, buying a house.
Yeah.
I'm moving, moving across the country.
So.
I'm getting them on the East coast.
So we're going back to East coast.
We're going to record in the same time zone eventually.
It's going to be clutch.
And actually there's, there's direct flights between where I live and where Joel lives twice per day.
Yep.
So we could hop down for an episode, hop back and it'd only be like a hundred bucks.
So that would be super clutch.
I'm very excited to have you back on the East coast.
So I'm, I'm looking forward to like four to five months from now.
And hopefully everything is a lot more chill.
I moved in.
I am not dealing with constant chaos.
This whole year has just been crazy, man.
From plumbing problems to house sales to just nonstop.
So yeah, I'm, I'm hoping this is, this is, uh, the bad karma side of the year and then the rest, it can only go up from here.
Right.
So.
So another thing that comes to mind about this event is, um, when you're working on a company that's very big and has a lot of different components and pieces to it, looking at auth is absolutely essential.
Look at understanding the auth flow very intimately is super important.
Yeah.
Because, um, especially when you've got companies that are, are buying other companies and, you know, sort of duct taping them into their own infrastructure.
Um, that auth piece is, is really, uh, really tricky to implement properly.
And, uh, and there's also a lot of things you can do with open redirects and with client side stuff.
And, oh, can I leak this specific piece of information by any of six different ways, you know?
And if you can, then you've really got a serious bug.
Yeah.
Well, I know you, I mean, you said I'm a good exploitationist.
You're at least as good as I am, if not better, bro.
Thanks, man.
Because like, to be honest, like in order to exploit those kinds of bugs, you have to have an intimate level of understanding of the application.
You've got to have gadgets too.
Right.
Because like, you might look at the authentication and be like, this, this is just standard OAuth.
Like, I don't know what to make of this.
Right.
But like, you have to try stuff.
You have to know what to try.
You have to have sort of that, that playbook of things to be testing, things that you've seen before, things that you've seen around the app as well.
Like other areas of login that you might be able to try.
And without that knowledge, like, you're just going to walk up to be like, this looks like OAuth.
Next.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, the knowledge of gadgets and the whole process and where it might break down between all of these different third parties, vendors, you know, sister applications, all of that sort of thing.
One of the things that's very interesting from the OAuth perspective is first party OAuth applications where you don't have to approve consent.
And third party applications where, you know, somebody can sign up and say, I want to use XYZ target for single sign on or whatever.
And that's something that I've been seeing a lot, even outside of this event is like, look very granularly at those flows and see if you can make any of them overlap.
Yeah.
Because the first party flows often don't require, you know, any sort of user interaction to release information.
Right.
And the third parties do.
And you can, you know, sign up for your own third party application.
Right.
So, that's another really, really cool area of interest that I've been kind of piquing my interest lately.
Yeah.
And then also, and then this is more relating to things before the event, but also things I've been hearing about the event, looking very closely at any third party software that is being brought into a hyper secure environment.
If you're dealing with a target that really takes security seriously, they may have a lot of their own shit on lock.
Yeah.
You know, and you may not be able to do much with that.
But when they say, okay, I'm going to bring into, you know, my application, this little weird feature, this little analytics tool or this little, you know, thing, you know, little widget.
Yep.
Then a lot of times they expose themselves to undue risk and they don't do enough security code review and, you know, threat modeling on those specific pieces of software.
I'm talking to you, Joel.
I'm talking to myself and I'm talking to the audience, you know, I know you know this.
Yeah. Well, I mean, honestly, like, and just to highlight sort of like, whenever I see a company implement something from the ground up, that is like a big red flag for me, especially if it's something that's common.
Right. If I see somebody re-implementing.
That's true. The flip side of this is very true as well.
Right. SAML, SSO, like any of that, that's like weird to me. I'm like, why didn't they just use some provider? Like, where did they mess up? Because did they read the RFC? Like, you know, how deep did they go on this?
That's true. And where can I find, you know, one little crack that I can exploit?
Yeah, it's kind of like a catch 22, right? Because if you use a third party, you know, maybe they're, you know, let's say SAML, like SAML is their shit. SAML is their thing. Right.
And, you know, you'd assume that their implementation would be better than your sort of, you know, off the cuff implementation.
But on the other side, you don't know because you can't see the code.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
So it's like, it's like, okay, do I trust this or do I not trust this?
Yeah. That is one of those things that draws me in all the time. I get so distracted by things because I'm like, we've talked about this. I'm a big dopamine hunter.
Yeah. So like whatever's like pulling my attention, I'll just like follow that. Yeah. And that, that caught me a couple times during this event. Like they were using a specific, especially in a highly obfuscated environment.
Yes. They were using a specific tool for obfuscation that really was piquing my interest. And so I kept getting pulled off to the side, like, Oh, how is this working? Oh, maybe I can find a way to like systemically figure out that. And it was just like, not really relevant, but I kept, it was like giving me so much dopamine that I was just like, Oh, I just gotta figure out how this thing works. Like, I don't even care if there's a bug here. I just want to know how it works. Like, you know, and, and, and this is why, this is why when we work together, it works really well. Cause I'd be like, Joel, are you staring at that end point?
Yeah. There's no bug there.
There's not even a hint of a bug there. He's like, I need to understand it.
Right. And so even if I see SAML, like say I see like somebody's using like, you know, octa or whatever for SAML, I'm like, maybe I can, maybe I can break octa. Like,
I am Sam.
Maybe TCP is the issue here.
Maybe there's a fundamental HTTP core problem.
Oh my gosh, dude.
So those, those sort of things exist. Um, oh, this is such a great tip. And I got to shout out, uh, Matan Bear for the,
uh, Matan Bear for this one. Cause he showed it to me. Um, and I went and read the HTML5 spec last night because I was so intrigued by this.
Did you know that image, I M A G E.
Is it a separate element from IMG?
No. Well, it is for SVG. Right.
But if you put, don't have it in an SVG context, the browser auto changes image to IMG.
Wait, what? On the client side?
Yeah. In the browser. So, so it's like, okay, you know, how many things can we bypass with that? Because you know, there's so many things saying like,
Everything is looking for image instead of image.
Exactly. And they're like, oh, this is an invalid HTML tag, you know, the outside of SVG or something like that. And it's literally, it's crazy. You go to your browser, you type in image, and you can even put on, you know, source and on, on error handles and that sort of thing.
And this is an HTML5 thing?
Yeah, it says specifically in the spec and it's hilarious too. If you go to the spec, it says, change the tokens tag to image. And then it says in this is in the, in the, in the HTML body section, what you should do when you run into a specific thing. And it says, don't ask is what it's.
Don't ask?
It says in quotes, no way. It says in quotes, don't ask. And then it was funny, you know, cause I was like, ah, man, I gotta find more of these. You know, if there's any of these other weird little things, nothing else. And, but I went through and it was funny.
It says, if you encounter the sarcasm, sarcasm tag, take a deep breath and move along is what it says.
No, I did.
Dude, I was just like, oh, wow.
How is the HTML5 spec actually an engaging read?
Wow.
It's like, this is great.
Dude.
I mean, it's.
So shout out to the HTML5 people. That was, it was, I laughed. I chuckled a couple of times.
That is so funny, dude.
Yeah.
Now I kind of want to go read through it too.
It's long.
It's massive.
When we were looking into that, um, uh, what was it? The body tag or something? The, uh, there was like the weird thing.
Oh, with meta or, um, base tag in the body tag. That was super weird. Yeah. That should not work according to the spec. But the, that's the thing, man, I really wish, um, Google Chrome or early Chromium would release a HTML5 as implemented by Chromium.
Mm.
Spec. So it's like, it's just a description, but it's how they've actually implemented it in Chromium. Right? Cause otherwise you've got to go and read this, you know, C.
Yeah. C code that's there.
Yeah. Dude, there are so many things that, that on that, like, that sort of aspect of stuff that like, I have to hold myself back from the dopamine hunting. Cause like, um, we were, when we were talking with Yusuf, we were talking about like the browser will decide whether or not the user has clicked on something.
To determine whether or not like an XSS should pop.
Right. Right.
And it's like, how does it, how does it determine that I've clicked on something?
Yeah.
That I've done an action. Like, how is it actually doing that?
How does the browser determine that? Like I clicked it instead of something else clicked it?
Dude, they're in for such a good episode, man. I can't even, it's going to be so good.
It's so good.
So good.
He drops Google Chrome bugs on the pod. It's like, it's amazing.
It's just like, oh yeah, there's this bug I had in Chrome. Like, you know, this common feature that everybody uses.
Yeah. It's such a great implementation.
Awesome. Awesome stuff.
Alrighty, man. Um, I'm exhausted.
Yeah, me too.
Let's go down and see if they're, it seems like they've paid a couple more bugs.
Nice.
So let's go, let's cut it for now and go check in on that.
Awesome. That's the pod, dude.
All right. That's the pod. Thanks y'all.
Peace.